お仕事している恰好する
私はお寺のことを助けて手伝ってるんだということはダメです
私はこうやって罰を与えられて
この罰をやってるんだということを言わなくちゃいけない
それから まあ一応寺から追い出すという項目があります
寺から追い出す で まあ一番厳しい罰っていうのは
出家から追い出すっていうこと
まあ寺から追い出すだったら
他のお寺でお世話になっても構いません
他の先生のところでお世話になって
そちらでいろいろ教えてもらって
まあ自分が自分の過ちを悔い改めるならば
また元のところに戻られますけど
でも他のところにお世話になったんだからって
その先生お坊さんは先生になりません
だからうまく逃げたっていうことになりません
先生がついてないと 自分の保護者がいないと
仏教教団ではもう通用しないんです
例えば比丘戒を受けたければ
誰かこのこのサンガっていうのは一つのソサエティだから
そのソサエティの前で何々さんが出家願ってますよと
このお坊さんの一人が報告しないといけないんですね
報告しなくて それでは誰がやってくれるんですかね
先生がいなきゃ大変なんです
これはあさりですか？あさりじゃない
そういうことだから厳しく
それはまあ本当にそれぐらい自分の心をね
今生の厳密にしたければ
やっぱりまあ回だけで足らないと思うならば
出家があります それででも足らないというならば
もっともっと大変なこの比丘戒があったりして
で まあそういうことで
この貪瞋痴では行動できないような
しないように このきちんと明確に目的を決めてる生き方をするんで
ですから 出家することによって出家僧として一人前になったということは
ただ単にこの戒律の段階を通ったっていうことだけなんです
戒 戒清浄って書いてある
まあその戒清浄を通ったということで
まあ普通の社会の方々にとっては
やっぱりこのこの戒律をよく覚えておいて
悟りを開きたいというならば
まず戒のことはこの項目を覚えるのは難しいんだから
それで項目を覚えたっても
もう全く偽善ばっかしで
それでもって人を馬鹿にしようと思っちゃいますからね
私は嘘は言わないんだと言っても
他人を馬鹿にしようとするんですね
そんな戒律じゃないんで
そういうものは ですから
もう無意味なんですね
守るよりは守らない方がいいと言いたいぐらいのところなんですね
守らないといくらか人間はできますからね
おおらかで やっぱり自分がダメな人間だということで生きているんだから
人間としては立派なんですね
ですから このこの項目だけというよりは
この貪瞋痴で行動しませんと
それは戒律だよと 決めたらそれぐらいで十分です
で それ終わったら次にあるのはチッタビスッディという心清浄ですね
心の清浄 この 言ってるのは
もし人が真剣真面目に戒清浄を頑張っちゃうと
もう心は落ち着いているんだと
もう怒りなんかは出る場がなくなっちゃうんですね
自我なんかはもう出る場がなくなっちゃうんですね
もう街道やらもうもう全てもう全くきれいさっぱり消しちゃうんですね
自分がいるという 例えば出家したならば
自分が何々さんで何々人でいるんだっていう
そのそこまで否定しちゃうんです
ですから このもう自我なんかは出る場がないんです
たとえ王様の息子が出家しようが
滅回の奴隷の息子が出家しようが
もう全部消すんです あんたはもう何者でもないんだと
これからは いわゆるわかりやすく言えば
この犯罪を起こして刑務所に行くでしょ
その場合は全部名前も全部消して番号をつけてるんですね
あなたは一ゼロ三三六やと
ただそれだけで一ゼロ三三六出てこいと
それ言えば出て行かなくちゃいけないんで
英語だったらイエスサーと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
何言っても あるいはあなたみたいにもあなたと言えないんだけどね
ものもう腐ってる もうもうネズミみたいです
イエスサーと言わなくちゃいけないんです
じゃああんた脳細胞一個もついてないのでは？なんて言ったらイエスサーと言わなくちゃいけないんです
何言うんですか？と刑務所に言ったらね
それはもう認めません
人を馬鹿にするんじゃないかと言っちゃったら
まあそれでもぶん殴られる
何言われたっても まあ軍隊も同じことですけど
まあイエスサーで言わなくちゃ通らなくちゃいけない
日本ではどういうか分かりませんだけど
刑務所に行ったことないんだけど
まあそろそろ行けるかもしれません
だからまあ一旦その自分に決まってる時間が終わって
外へ出る瞬間まで名前はないんですね
出勤したら同じく名前消しちゃうんですね
そしてまあだから人間
まあ世の中にあるこの世俗的な世間にあるこのくだらない身分とか
そういうのは全部捨てなくちゃいけないんです
だからこの そういうことだから
かなり煩悩というかね
それは一つももう働くなくなっちゃう
働い働くこと自分で生活できなくなる
だから自分が控えた方が
自分という自分の高慢を消した方が
消しておけばおくほど
すごく楽に生きていられるんです
自分の目的を達成することはできるんです
ですから この戒だけ守ると
次のステージに自動的に進んじゃうんです
心清浄に もう心が清らかになるでしょうに
当たり前なんです もう心にもう怒りも欲もどんどん生まれなくなっちゃうんです
安定して この平安な心になってくるんです
ですから 戒から始めなくてはどうしてもできないもので
戒から始めたら 心のところはすぐもうあれ成功すると
次にもう心の方はもうスタートしているんです
つなげているんです で
アビダンマでは心清浄って何ですか？という場合
これはサマーディだと統一性だと
心は落ち着いていることだとと説明しているんですね
その中にこの色界の禅定
無色界の禅定 そこまで全部入るんです
例えば人が瞑想する 瞑想したら第一禅定
二禅定 第三禅定 第四禅定
アビダンマ的に言えば第五禅定まで作ったとする
だから禅定を作ったら
この二番目の清浄のステージに至ったことになります
あるいはそれ上にある無色界の四つの禅定ありますね
苦無辺やら色無辺やらね
そういう無色界の禅定を全部まとめた
まとめたらこの八つですけど
この八つの禅定 八つか九つかどっちでもいいんだけど
この禅定を作ることのただヴィパッサナーの場合は第二番目のステージ
それで怒りがあったり
欲があったり 嫉妬があったり
高慢があったりすると
心っていうのはものすごく乱れちゃうんですね
安定しないんですね すごく揺れるんです
で それで戒律を守ることによって
心のこの乱れな波をね
抑えてもらっちゃうと
ちゃんと瞑想ができるようになって
すぐ禅定を作ると思えば作られます
時々このヴィパッサナー瞑想を実践する方々もね
私にまで教えようとしているのはそういうところなんですね
だから瞑想 ヴィパッサナー始めたら全く荒っぽい
このできてない 成長していない心で始まりますから
怒りがあったり 憎しみがあったり
高慢があったり 自信がもう自信喪失やらいろいろ精神的な問題いっぱいあるでしょうに
そういうのはもうサティでもって確認すると
まあどんどんまあコントロールできてなくなっていくようになるんですね
あれは単なるサマーディのレベルなんです
あれで全部消えたわけじゃないんです
あ これ不思議だ もうすぐ怒れなくなりましたとかね
で来て私に説教したっても
あ それでよかったということを反応しますけど
でも世界は別やと言いたいところもあります
あんた怒らなくなったということは
第二番目のまあ何かですって言うんですか
あの 一来果？一来果にでも悟ったんですかと
あるいは不還果まで悟ったんですか？とも聞きたいんだけど
だからこの そういうことではなくて
やっぱり本人にとってはいろんな悩みやら苦しみやらどんどん出てきて
そこをサティでもって消えていって
落ち着いてる心が出来上がっちゃうんですね
だからこの長い間ヴィパッサナーやって何をしているかというと
結局このサマーディ状態の戦いなんです
そこで落ち着いて人格ができたならば
第3ステージにチャレンジできるんです
たとえ瞑想したっても
人のことは許さないとかと喧嘩するとか
わがままとかね この これ一番ポイントはこのサンガなんで
サンガはいつでも僧は皆様の
あの 何と言いますか 帰依する対象でしょう
だからヴィパッサナーする人は
にとっては それは絶対的な帰依の対象なんです
自分を だから信仰対象じゃないんです
これは鏡なんです で そこを見て自分を直さなくちゃいけないんです
そのための帰依なんです
帰依っていうのはもうリフュージだから避難するところなんです
危険があったらそこは避難所なんです
ですから この心に危険が起きたら
この仏法僧はいつでも自分には鏡になって
まあそこら辺 そこら辺直せということを言ってるんです
ですから このサンガそのものが
この戒律の あの完全たる生き方を象徴しているものなんです
サンガ一人一人は戒律を完璧に守っているわけじゃないんです
人間だからいろいろ間違いはします
一人一人は でもサンガ通してみると
これは完全なもうシステムなんです
だからそちらでは たとえ私は今年上の坊主だと言っても
何の権力もないんで サンガになってきたならば
例えば１０人のサンガが集めたとすれば
私は一番年上かもしれませんだけど
全然その力がないんです
たった一票の力しかないんです
やたらに反対することは決してできません
やたらに自分の意見を通してもらおうということもできません
こういう意見ですけど
いかがでしょうかとみんなに聞いて行動しなくちゃいけない
だから たとえ大長老であろうが
サンガとしてコミュニティとして集めたら
いつでも自我を置いといて
もうみんなと仲良く水と水と水が一緒になるような感じで
どのように生きていられるかって
これはポイントなんです
そこで私は別人だよと言っちゃったら
もうそれでもう性格はできてないんですね
水の中に油を入れちゃったら
それは溶けないんですね
そこでサンガは出来上がりません
水に水を入れてみたっても
ただ量が増えるだけでもうどちらかとわからなくなっちゃうでしょ
どんな水ですかと 一旦入れちゃえば
その心 その性格が出てこないと
もう 第2ステージで止まっちゃうんです
これからこの話 私は一度も聞き
言いたくないところですけどね
一旦言っちゃえば まあ仏教をやめるか
どちらか どちらかに決めるしかないんだけど
甘くないかもしれません
ですから たとえヴィパッサナー瞑想だけでも構いませんだけど
それで 第1ステージ まあ 第1は外離作の境ですけど
それから 第2心の問題でしょう
で 心はできて出来上がってもらう
このどんなような心が出来上がったというと
どんな生命に対しても対立しない
自分が偉そうなすごいできてる別人だと
聖者だと思わない 相手がキリスト教であろうが無神教であろうが
男であろうが女であろうが
そういう あるいは犬猫ゴキブリであろうが
まあそんな分別差別ない心で
みんなに優しく丁寧に
行動できるぐらい心の落ち着きが必要なんです
それも偽善はダメ じゃあ私は今日からそういう風にやりますと
私はそうじゃあ頑張ってくださいというだけで
これ本物か偽物かこれはまるっきり見えますからね
ただ自分がそういう人間になる
偽善だったら偽善でもいいんだけど
かなり精神的にストレスは溜まる
例えば気持ち悪いゴキブリに対して
ああ やっぱり可愛いですねとか思うのは
これはちょっと無理でしょうね
[背景音楽]だから本当のお釈迦様を目指した世界っていうのは
もうものすごい美しい世界と私は言うのはそういうわけで
本当に仏教の気持ちが心に入ったならば
それだけでも人間ができているんです
そういう人々はすっごく信頼できるんです
ただ単にお数何枚かとかね
それでは決めるもんじゃないんです
服は仏教修行者は白い色を着ます
着ますから 服は全部捨てて白い色だけに決まったんですかとか
髪の毛伸ばしたか あるいは結んでおいてくれと
そういうものではないんです
だから表の飾りではないんですよ
その人そのものが その人の人格自体が大変信頼できる人格になるはずなんです
だからそこはいくらなんとかして持っていきたいために
この必死になってこの慈悲の瞑想を紹介しているんです
私一人だけですけどね
なかなかチャレンジを受けてる人はいませんだけど
とにかくケチつけたくてつけたくて
時々ミャンマーまで行ってくるんです
私にケチつけようと ミャンマー道場で慈悲の瞑想を教えませんだから
それはそちらにはもうちゃんとした論理があって
そうやってるんであって
ですから この 大変なこの難しい世界ですから
とにかくこの まあ慈悲の実践もちゃんとうまくできたならば
もう性格がこの第1ステージに
もう必要な この本当に完全な状態になってくるんですね
それとヴィパッサナー瞑想も組み合わせると
まあ怒りも欲も高慢も葛藤も憎しみも
もうすぐ処理できる 怒ってしまえば
すぐ瞬時にその怒りを収めてもらって
もう怒りでない心で喋ったり行動したりすることができるようになってしまうんですね
それだったらいつでも心は安定していて
心に統一が出来上がっちゃうんです
だから そういう風に この 第1と第2番目のステージを合格しなくちゃいけないんです
じゃあ そこを過ぎたところで
3番目のディッティヴィスッティ
ラッカンラサパッチュパッターナパダッターナヴァセナナマルーパパリッガホディッティヴィスッティ名目とこちらで書いてあって
これはこのゲンミッスに意味だけ書いてるんですね
特徴作用原状直接因による名称の把握を顕正症状という
それでわかりますね だからこの 293 ページのところからは
一般的には理解できない世界なんです
1  2 はなんとか説明できますけどね
3 からはもう世界です
でもそれぞれ瞑想経験ある方々にはわかるかもしれませんし
これまあ一応わかりやすく説明しますが
あのヴィパッサナーでは解釈しないで
ただ確認だけしていくんです
で どうせ心は育ててない人だから
心成長していないんだから
まあ確認と言ったっても
まあそれはそれなりの確認なんですね
それ別に間違ってるわけじゃないんです
まあ子供も 1歳  2歳の子供も自転車に乗りますけど
やっぱり補助輪というんですか
それ 2つもついてるんだから
まあ自転車と言うべきか
4輪車と言うべきか まあどっちかわかりませんだけど
でも我々にはそれは別に
あんたまだ自転車に乗れませんと
これ 4輪車ではないかというからかはしません
からかうところがもうちゃんとそれついてるかと
それついていて それでよく偉そうに自転車こいでいると褒めてあげたりもします
上手ですよと それでちっちゃな子供の顔なんか見ると
この自転車に乗って この偉そうな顔を見るともうどうだいと私の出来栄えっていう感じで
本人もすごくもうすごい満足な顔で偉そうな顔をして
いろんなことこういうとか言いますけど
でもそれで終わっ 人生は終わらないでしょう
やがてあの補助輪を外しちゃうでしょうし
それからどんどんどんどんその乗り物のことも成長していくでしょう
そういうことだから とにかく乗ればいいということなんです
で どんどん上手に乗ればいいと
まあまあ 最初はもう簡単に何か確認する
自分でもう分かったものは膨らみでいいし
縮み膨らみでも色欲しいし
痛みでも何でもいいんです
自分で分かったものを確認していけば
解釈だけしないで で そこでサマーディが集中力がどんどん増してくるんですね
それはものを見る 例えば
これはこの 虫眼鏡でもいいし
顕微鏡みたいなものに例えると
どんどん倍率が高くなるんです
集中力というのは そういうことなんです
初めは目で見る それから普通の虫眼鏡で見る
それからもっと立派な虫眼鏡で見ると
それからほんのちょっと軽いおもちゃみたいな顕微鏡で見るとかね
それたらなと もうちょっと倍率のいい顕微鏡でも持ってみるとかね
そうやってどんどんどんどんこの見る角度を鋭くなっていくんですね
それはサマーディなんです
だからヴィパッサナーで観察する
観察する この倍率をどんどんどんどん増えていかなくちゃいけないんですね
だから心のことだから
自分で強引に倍率を上がってもらおうと思ったら
それはもう自然なものだから
それは不可能なんです
今日種まいて もう明日しか時間ないんだから
じゃあ明日花咲いてもらいますよと言ったっても
それは生きているものだから
そんなわがままは利かないんですね
機械だったらいいかもしれませんだけど
でも生き物だからわがままは利かないんですね
時間取るんです 成長には
だから顕微鏡だったらもうお金さえあればすぐじゃあ買いますよと言って買ってもいいんだけど
でも顕微鏡も上プロクラスに行けば行くほど扱いにしにくいんです
ただ 虫眼鏡でものを見た人にとっては
プロ級のかなりの倍率の眼鏡って使えないでしょうに
全く無理なんです なぜかというと
虫眼鏡だったらほんの
でもこうやって見ればいいんだけど
顕微鏡の場合はそんなことは聞きません
やっぱり見るものもそれなりの小さいものを取って見られるようにいろいろ工夫して
この見るスライドですか
それを作らなくちゃいけないんです
そこで当たる光やらいろんなもうまたいろんな見るものをはっきり見えるために
いろんな液体付け加えたりしたりするし
そこは大変な世界なんです
だから偉そうなことをお金だけ払って買ってきたっても
まるっきり使えないんです
だから顕微鏡にしたってのも
どんどんじわじわと勉強した方が正しいんですね
そうやって確認することが上手に確認できるようになる
私はこのすごく気をつけて
そういう言葉を使っているはずなんです
できるだけ上手に確認してくださいと
上手に確認できるようにしてください
ただそれだけ 私は希望するのは
この上手にという言葉にはすごく意味があるんです
聞き逃しちゃいますけどね
だから聞き逃しているんだっていうことは
もう全くも分かりますからね
聞く質問やら話す時やらね
もう全く違うことなんですね
ですから この 上手に確認してくださいということで
この倍率 集中力の倍率を上げることと考えているんです
そこで何のことなく膨らみと縮みだけばっかし見ていた人がね
いろんなものを現象を確認できるようになってくるんです
今まで自分の体で心で気付い
気づかなかったいろんなことに確認できるようになる
それでもその人はさらに上手に確認してもらうんです
そうするともっといろんなものを確認できるようになります
大体何を確認するで何を確認するかっていうことは
この瞑想の世界では言わないんですね
言った途端 これ偽になっちゃうんですね
それじゃあ次にあなたはこういうこういうことを確認しますよと言ったら
次にそのものを言ってくれるんです
私はこういうこういう風にしました
あれは嘘なんです だからそれだったらもう意味がないんですね
もう本当に可哀想なことになりますからね
だからこれだけは言わないことにします
上手に確認してみてください
だから確認して終わって帰ってから
あなた何を確認したんですかと
そこを聞いてもらう それ見たら上手に言ってるかないかっていうことはわかりますから
だから顕微鏡の倍率を上げると
今何を見ているんですか？と言ったところで
今はこういう風に見えてますと言ったら
それはその通りかないかとわかるでしょうね
まあだからとにかくこのアビダルマの説明でも
そこはだいたい言わないように置いておきますけど
あの浄土論を読んでみても明確に説明あるんだからといって
あの やっぱりそれでも気をつけて書いてるんですね
まあ修行する人は偽善者にならないように
だからこのそこら辺だから読んでも何でしょうかとわからない可能性はあります
それは何でしょうかとわからないだけっても
瞑想すればいいことなんですけど
書こうとすれば書けます
それだけは書かないと
書いちゃったら この心の働きから見れば
もう必ずしも一人も悟れないで
口先だけではみんな悟っていると
そうすると同じ世間と同じことになっちゃいます
仏教の国だったら 国全体みんな悟っているんだけど
戦争をしているんだと
お互いに殺し合いをやってるんだということになっちゃうんです
今の世界 誰一人嘘言わないでしょ？誰一人も殺生しないでしょ？そんなことと同じくなっちゃうんです
悟ってはいるんだけど
あのお坊さんがもうのことを絶対許せませんと
と喧嘩すると いうことになりかねません
そういうことだから そこら辺はやっぱり
言わない どれぐらい言わないかというと
この悟ったお坊さんにしたっても
絶対口を裂けんでも言わないと
それぐらい厳密にこの個人の経験したものとかね
観察したものとかね どのように心成長していったんですかっていうことは言わないことにしているんです
別にお釈迦様はそう言ってはいけませんと言っているわけでもないんです
なんとなく まあずっと伝統の中でそうなってはいるんですね
あるお坊さんが書いたテキストに
あの最近の信者さんたちにね
あんた方は仏教のわからない馬鹿者たちで
もう何て言いますか 我々この信仰深い人々をよく馬鹿にするんです
何信仰と言うんですかね
あのすごい向こうの言葉がありまして
このいわゆる愚か者の信仰ような意味でね
だから信仰深いというとイコール愚か者という感じもするんです
だからそんな信仰でお坊さんたちに
そういう世界のことをね
瞑想のこととか平気で聞くんだと
それだけはやめなさいと
あんた方は悟りとか そういうことを理解したければ
自分で瞑想してみなさいと
お坊さんはどこまで悟っているんですか？とか
それはどういうことですか？とかね
すごいかっこつけて聞いたりするので
それだけはやめなさいと
で そのお坊さんの本で
この嘘を言ったってもね
殺生したっても あの なんとかなりますよと
これはもうなんとなりませんと
こんなことやっちゃってしまえばということで
厳しく もうそれはもう最近と言ったっても
それほど最近じゃないんだけどね
まああの 私は学生の時読んだ本だからね
古い本ですけど テキストで
まあそのお坊さんがそうやって初めに書いたんだけど
もっと古い文献ではそんなことは書いてないんです
とにかくこの何を確認しますかということは明確に言っちゃうと
そういう風に人間偽善だからごまかしちゃうんですね
ごまかしちゃうと心はそのまんまで止まっちゃうんです
じゃあとにかくディッティスッディの場合の何を確認するかというと
今もう分かりやすく説明する途中でしたけど
とにかく物事を確認していく
確認していくと その人によって
例えば体だったら 体が物体一つ物体として明確に見える
はずなんです それで この物体的な体の中に
この心という働きが入り込んでいること
手と言ったっても 手は物体なんですけど
手の中にまた心という厄介なやつも入り込んで入り込んでいる
そこで一般俗人が手と言うんだけど
そっちには種類の働きがあるんだと
一般の人は私の体とも言うんだけど
それはそうではなくて
ある物体とその中にまたあるエネルギーが入り込んじゃって
まあ不可分な状態でもう行動してますけど
明確に違うと そのつは見えてきます
それは先に言ったら ああ
そうか そうですと すぐその段階は自分が突破したような感じで錯覚するんです
そうすると意味がないんですね
だからこの私はもう子供の頃から説法していたんだから
これはものすごくわかりやすく説明するのはいとも簡単なんですけど
もう説得力あるように
それでいいかどうかちょっとわからないんですね
一応体ということに 一般の人にとっては体ということは私であって
大事なものであって もう大事なものなんですけど
自分にとってはすべて邪魔は体であるということはまた理解できていないんですね
例えば瞑想なぜできないんですかね
これ体のせいでしょうに
座っていたら痛くてたまらないと
あるいはもう年でもうなかなか座っていられないんだと
体が太りすぎてなかなか姿勢正しく守れないで
それも体のせいでしょうに
足は曲がりませんと 腰が痛いんだと
年取ってくると大体骨なんかは弱くなるでしょうに
だから年取ってくると瞑想っていうのはものすごいきつい
もうかわいそうなんです
やらせるのも 見ていられないほど大変なことなんです
ですから この一般の人にとって
お腹がすいたとか 疲れましたとか
それでろくに瞑想できないでしょう
寒いと熱いとか ありったけの文句を言うんじゃないんですか
なんで瞑想したって もういろいろトラブルあるんですかね
場所はないとかね どこ行って瞑想しようかとか
それも体のややこしいことでしょうに
だから自分の体をどんな場所に置くかということによって
どれぐらいお金がかかるか
かからないかと それまで決めるでしょうに
例えば冬だったら沖縄とか
そこら辺が一番環境はいいかも
南に近いんだから 地球の波動もそれなりによろしいし
瞑想しやすいと思いますけど
でもこの体はもう沖縄まで運んじゃうと毎日毎日どれぐらいお金かかるかと
そうやってもう体っていうのはもう結構迷惑だらけなんですけど
我々はそこにすごく引っ張られて足かせになって何もできない状態になっているんですね
で そこで一般瞑想していない人にとっては
自分と体はイコールになっているんです
ヴィパッサナーは確認だけずっと続けると
自分と体はイコールという概念がちょっとずれちゃうんですね
体は体で 心は心でと 例えば足が痛いと言ったって
いつでも足が痛いわけじゃないんです
足に心が入っているんだから痛いんだよと
足が曲がったんだから痛いわけじゃない
それだったら曲がるたびに痛いはずなんです
足が曲がっちゃうと痛いんだったら
それは心の問題ではありません
かもしれませんよ その方は足は曲がりませんだから私の足が弱くて曲がりませんと
アーティティスでもう硬くなってるんだと